jeremy corbyn says effectively he
doesn't agree with renewing trident even
though it's the party position the party
says that they think that try dat should
be reviewed renewed what do you think
personally I think that the party has
decided that we continue to renew
Trident and the decision has been made
and generally the public seems to be in
favor of us having a new collegiate a
short what's your view though I think
that we need to look at 21st century
threats and I don't think that Trident
is a top priority for me I think that
the biggest threat from Russia is things
like what cyber attacks I mean I was
saying this a year ago you know actually
the cyber capability of Russia is is in
terms of 21st century threat that's a
more immediate problem for us you know
and the way in which they try to
undermine democracy in the West through
their propaganda through funding all
sorts of organizations that is the way
in which actually this is the modern
stuff so you personally disagree then
with the party policy on try to I'm not
getting involved in any more fights
about this you know party policy is
party policy my view is is that we
should not take our eye off the main
game which is that the real threat from
Russia is actually much more modern much
more subtle much more nuanced and real
now